everybody sleeps but not all of us know
how important sleep is hi
I'm Ravi Isola and I'm a professor of
clinical sleep medicine at UCLA today
I'm going to debunk some myths about
sleep so we can all work on getting a
better night's sleep
[Music]
our limbs are paralyzed during REM sleep
that is not a myth that is true
there's circuitry within the brain
especially during REM sleep that
actually inhibits our skeletal muscle
tone this is the we don't act out what
we're dreaming about and accidentally
hurt ourselves REM sleep or rapid eye
movement sleep which is about 20% of the
total time you sleep is a unique
neurologic and physiologic state our
eyes are moving rapidly during that time
while the rest of our body's muscles are
almost in paralyzed state except for the
breathing and eye muscles it's when we
tend to drink is also when our brains
are very active you may have woken up
sometimes from a nap or if you're
particularly sleep-deprived feeling like
your mind is awake but you can't move
your body
that's sleep paralysis it can be really
scary but it's not dangerous it can
happen in people who've just been
chronically sleep-deprived or it may be
a sign of a sleep disorder some
disorders of sleep especially REM sleep
can result in inappropriate muscle
inhibition and paralysis during
wakefulness people with narcolepsy which
is a disorder of sleep wake regulation
in the brain can actually experience
what we refer to as cataplexy this can
occur when they're surprised excited or
laughing and can result in them
collapsing to the ground even in extreme
cases we have animals that do this as
well certain breeds of dogs experience
cataplexy and when they get excited they
may actually collapse we only sleep with
our eyes shut that's actually a myth
some people may have their eyes
partially open during sleep this can't
happen in people who are experiencing
eye problems or other medical problems
that affect the eye it can also happen
in people who are really sleep deprived
our brains have the ability to have
microsleeps
we go to sleep for a very brief period
of time and aren't even aware of it this
especially happens if we're
sleep-deprived and can happen with our
eyes open
having hemispheric sleep is adaptive for
an aquatic mammal because it makes sure
that they still are able to go up to the
surface to breathe as well as be aware
of predators there's some data that
suggests that humans may experience
regional sleep this may be times where
our eyes are open but we're not really
registering what's going on because
parts were brain are not fully awake
especially if we're sleep-deprived
everyone needs seven hours of sleep
that's a myth the reason you often hear
that seven hours of sleep is the magic
number of hours of sleep we need is
based on a large number of studies that
have looked at populations and doesn't
necessarily mean that every individual
needs exactly seven hours some people
need less some people may need more the
important thing is not just how much
sleep but it's the quality of sleep and
how you feel after you've slept chronic
insufficient sleep less than seven hours
a night and especially less than six
hours a night is associated with an
increased risk of obesity diabetes
cardiovascular disease and mood
disorders like depression and anxiety
how much we sleep and when we sleep
changes over our lifespan parents often
complain about their lazy teenagers that
they can't get up in the morning and get
to school during adolescence
this is physiologic and normal now that
we've recognized that wanting to stay up
later and wake up later is normal for
teens a number of states have
implemented policies to delay school
start times for teens you can catch up
on lost sleep that's true but it's
really important when you catch up on
that sleep and how you catch up on that
sleep sleep deprivation is bad for you
both in the short term and the long term
acute sleep deprivation can have
negative effects on everything from your
mood your appetite as well as your
cognitive performance sleep debt is not
getting enough sleep that our bodies and
brains need over a long period of time
we can pay that debt back to a degree
what's critical is when we pay that
sleep
back one way to do this is take a
powernow I think the best time to take a
nap is in the early afternoon sometime
between 1:00 and 4:00 for most people
it's a natural dip in our circadian
rhythms when we tend to be a little bit
more sleepy during the 24-hour day
circadian rhythms are 24-hour biologic
rhythms that we have developed over time
our planet goes through phases of light
and dark day and night and so our
behavior adjusts accordingly some people
have a really hard time napping
especially when the Sun is out we'd like
to mimic the environment that we sleep
in at night so keep it dark or put some
dark sunglasses on anything that helps
your body feel like it's time to take a
nap can you learn something new while
you sleep the answer is much more
complicated than a simple yes-or-no
you're not gonna learn the language just
by playing language tapes while you're
sleeping if you've been working on
something during the day and trying to
learn something new
auditory cues during the night to help
reinforce that knowledge may help the
key is we don't want to disrupt sleep
while we're trying to do that more time
in bed does not mean more sleep if
you're lying in bed wake looking around
and especially if you're lying in bed
getting frustrated that you're not
sleeping and worrying about how you're
gonna do the next day or when you're
gonna finally get some sleep or how many
hours you're gonna sleep it's not
helping the problem there are things we
can do to optimize our sleep having a
comfortable mattress making sure that
your body is not experiencing stress
points or that your muscles and joints
are not misaligned during sleep can help
improve the quality of your sleep some
people find that using a weighted
blanket helps them feel more secure
during sleep and that weight on their
body as well as potentially near their
forehead helps calm them though were
warm-blooded animals our body
temperatures not saying throughout the
day the lowest point of our body
temperature is when we're in deep sleep
in some cases cooling our heads as we're
trying to fall asleep may actually help
us fall asleep some people have tried to
do things as simple as putting a cool
compress on their head
they're trying to fall asleep a lot of
people claim a hot or warm bath before
sleep helps it actually may help cool
the body because the blood flows going
out to the surface cooling our core a
little bit more and that may help us
fall asleep we also don't want to
necessarily be productive when we can't
sleep
because the goal is to calm my nervous
systems down better off getting up and
doing something that I would say is dull
boring in in dim light we want to try to
avoid bright light especially blue light
because that can get us activated again
make it even more difficult to fall
asleep melatonin supplements help you
sleep that's true melatonin is actually
a hormone made in a part of the brain
called the pineal gland melatonin helps
our body regulate our sleep/wake cycles
naturally supplements that contain
melatonin may not be good for you the
problem with supplements is they're not
all the same and the dose of melatonin
the timing of it and how much actually
gets into our body can vary a lot
depending on the type of supplement we
take the timing and the dose of
melatonin are important because our
bodies react to melatonin at different
times during the day depending on what
we're trying to achieve we may want to
give a low dose of melatonin several
hours before we go to sleep or a higher
dose right before bedtime melatonin
supplements and melatonin treatment may
be appropriate for people with certain
types of sleep disorders taking a
high-quality melatonin supplement to
help fall asleep when you're dealing
with an unusual situation like jetlag or
shift work may be appropriate but taking
melatonin supplements all the time may
be covering up a problem that needs be
looked into
insomnia is all in your head that's a
myth insomnia is when people may have
trouble falling asleep staying asleep or
waking up before they intend to insomnia
can be related to both issues relating
to our minds and our bodies sleep
disorders and mood disorders are really
interconnected and both can affect each
other we're having difficulty coping
with our feelings and emotions that can
certainly impact our sleep and vice
versa if we're not sleeping well we
often have a
tough time regulating our emotions as
well trouble falling asleep can be
related to the way we deal with stress
or anxiety or if we have trouble
shutting off our brains as we try to get
to sleep trouble staying asleep may be a
problem with the way we're breathing
during sleep or movements during sleep
if you've done your best to improve your
sleep environment and your sleep hygiene
and habits and still suffer from
disrupted sleep and waking up frequently
at night that may be a sign of a sleep
disorder and that may be a time to get
advice from a medical specialist snoring
is harmless that's definitely a myth
when we sleep our muscles relax
including the muscles in the back of the
throat depending on the size and shape
of the soft tissues in the back of the
throat
the consul's the uvula which hangs in
the roof of the mouth and the tongue as
well as the size of our jaw the position
that we sleep in medications we may be
taking all these factors may interact to
cause some people to partially or
completely collapse the airway during
sleep partial collapse and vibration of
that tissue causes a snore sound so
concerning be harmful if the snoring is
actually more than just snoring and
interfering with our breathing and
causing oxygen levels to drop then we
call it sleep apnea sleep apnea is when
our bodies experience repetitive
collapse of the airway during sleep
causing disruption and sleep in drops in
oxygen levels if this goes on for a long
period of time untreated it can result
in symptoms of insomnia frequent
nighttime awakenings
waking up tired or foggy headed and
daytime sleepiness over the long term it
can increase the chances of other health
problems like high blood pressure
diabetes and mood disorders in the u.s.
about a third of people with sleep apnea
are not overweight sleep apnea is more
common in men than women but women can
develop sleep apnea too especially after
menopause if someone tells you you snore
or you know that you snore and
especially if someone has commented that
they've seen you stop breathing at night
that may be a sign of sleep apnea and
you should probably get that checked out
by a doctor
we eat eight spiders a year while we're
sleeping
that is definitely a myth we only five
spiders a night when we're asleep just
kidding when we sleep we may inhale or
micro aspirate stuff that's in our mouth
this is usually not a big problem
we don't swallow or chew when we're
sleeping as much as we would while we're
awake thanks for tuning in I hope this
information today will help you get a
better night's sleep and better health
sweet dreams